in this video we'll be talking about
cellular senescence cellular senescence
is a process
or it's a state of the cell
where the permanent growth arrest
happens and the cell lose its ability to
divide further
so cell growth and division capability
is permanently abrogated
let's talk about the Hallmarks of
cellular senescence
so what really discriminates a senescent
cell from a normal cell
it turns out there are accumulation of
specific enzyme known as senescence
Associated beta galactosidase or S beta
gal which is a characteristic feature of
the senesen cell
there are many other features for
example there is an abnormally enlarged
and flat appearance of the senescent
cell when compared to a normal cell
in technical words the increase in
nucleus to cytoplasmic ratio is one of
the discriminating feature of a
senescent cell so the cytoplasm become
bigger and the nucleus becomes smaller
in this case
also there are other markers such as
lack of DNA replication or increased
level of p21 or p16 which are proteins
known as cyclin-dependent kinase
Inhibitors all these factors actually
inhibits the cycling dependent kinases
which are key regulator of cell cycle
progression
in simple words these proteins ensure
the cell cycle or cell division
processes are stopped or paused
then senescence cells show A peculiar
feature of
nuclear senescence Associated
heterochromatin Focus so if you zoom
into the nucleus so there are several
focus of the heterochromatin which are
very characteristics of a senescent cell
and that's a Hallmark feature as well
now recently scientists are taking
transcriptomic approach to look at what
are the genes different between normal
and a senator Cena sense cell what are
the chromatin changes in a normal and
senescence cell and what are the
trajectory of different Pathways in
these cell types
also quantitative proteomic approach
allows the scientists to understand
which proteins are differentially
enriched or deprived in these two
different cellular States also where
these proteins are located in which
pathway they are involved so what
pathway are upregulated or down
regulated in this senescent cell
all these complementary approach can
give us better understanding about a
senescent cell because this is a
cellular state that we need to
understand
anyway let's talk about the features and
the inducers of cellular senescence
it turns out prolonged DNA damage
response or DDR response
then telomere shortening and damage
oncogenic activation all these could be
a trigger for cellular senescence
all this thing can lead to a pause of
the cell cycle
which further lead to senescence and
this kind of allows the senescent
features to be upregulated or be more
prominent for example
the nuclear senescence Associated
heterochromatin Focus are pretty
characteristics
of senescence then there are is beta gal
accumulation elevated level of
anti-apoptotic protein
then increased level of cdk Inhibitors
all of these things defines the cellular
and molecular features of a senosine
cell it is important to note that
senescence is very different from
apoptosis senescence means a kind of
like a pause state
an apoptosis program cell death in fact
the cellular senescence are percolate
proteins of bcl2 family which prevents
the probability of a cell undergoing
apoptosis
now Ros level increase or reactive
oxygen species level increase is another
characteristic feature of cellular
senescence
while a cell undergoes senescence it's
metabolically active but the normal
metabolism in mitochondria and many
other organelles are altered
another key feature of senescent cell is
this secret several molecules all these
molecules are collectively known as
senescence Associated secretory
phenotype and these molecules are of
like say several interleukins monocyte
chemo attracting factors Matrix
metalloproteinases which can
attract and modify the cellular
environment
now these obviously
can possibly attract cell types
and it can also damage many cells it can
evoke inflammation in many other
epithelial cells one of the key goal of
these mole secreted molecules to attract
the attention of the immune system
and in a moment it would be clear why so
let's talk about the disease angle and
cellular senescence
so cellular senescence is thought to be
one of the key driver of aging process
senescence is one of the nine Hallmarks
of Aging so we always wondered why do we
age and one of the key feature while we
age is the cellular senescence
now in many disease for example
idiopathic pulmonary fibrosis senesin
cells accumulates in the lung epithelial
layer and these NSN cells cause a lot of
problems because they a they can attract
other immune cells evoke inflammation
and it has been shown that
when these cells are eliminated somehow
that leads to a recovery so question is
how these senescent cells can be removed
are there therapeutic approaches to
remove the senescent cells it turns out
yes there are therapeutic approaches to
get rid of these saracen cells and these
are known as cenolytics so there are
plethora of drugs which Target several
Pathways that are involved in senescence
and eliminate these cells selectively
but many a times these synolytics Target
molecules which are overlapping in many
Pathways and that's why it could be also
detrimental for the body
there are other approaches such as
immune therapy such as inkt cell
mediated immune immune therapy which
selectively eliminates these senescence
cells and doesn't harm the other body
cells so though expensive this immune
therapy is very promising for future
therapeutic approaches scientists and
researchers are continuously racing to
find out new Solutions towards
senescence
now let's talk about a beneficial aspect
of cellular senescence so far we talked
about all the harmful and all kind of
like pathological aspects of senescence
but senescence could be beneficial
because think about this way if it's a
so bad pathway or a cellular program
then why even it exists why it is not
eliminated by a natural selection it
doesn't seem if it is that doesn't seem
to be beneficial
so are we missing something it turns out
yes because senescence could be very
useful for wound healing and it has been
demonstrated in modern organism
zebrafish
it also turns out that
senescence can prevent oncogenic
transformation of the tumor cells so it
kind of have a tumor suppressor kind of
role or maybe it prevents the conversion
of a tumor or aggressive growth of a
tumor and it can do that by pausing the
cells capability to divide which is
crucial for tumor formation in that
sense senescence is beneficial
then cellular senescence is actually not
bad so we should update our
understanding
so if senescence cells are not timely
removed that is something which is
detrimental for the cellular biology
so the homeostatic function of
senescence cell depends on their
elimination by the immune system
so these are some senescent cells that
would attract cells like dendritic cell
NK cells macrophages neutrophils and
eventually the senescent cells would be
removed and that is how our body
protects itself from undergoing
senescence but once it is not removed
properly that cause a problem and that's
the Genesis for aging and many other
disease
so that kind of concludes the video on
cellular senescence and here is a quick
summary about the key features of
cellular senescence that we have
discussed in this video If you like this
video give it a quick thumbs up you can
get more notes and flashcards in our
Facebook page or Instagram page follow
us on that links are provided in
description you can support our Channel
using super tanks you can pay via paytm
PayPal or UPI see you in next video
everything